[Musique]
bienvenue au qatar un ami me rappelle
plus grand que la corse mais un pays
richissime
le troisième producteur de gaz au monde
est une réserve de pétrole estimées à
700 milliards d'euros le qatar un pays à
la rencontre de deux cultures
à 7000 km paris place de l'étoile
à l'hôtel particulier
l'ambassade du qatar l'une des plus
imposantes de la capitale
ce jour là l'ambassadeur son excellence
mohamed el gohary reçoit l'élite
française d'origine arabe
dans l'assistance aux fonctionnaires
médecins ingénieurs
je suis très heureux de vous accueillir
c'est soir à l'ambassade du qatar à
paris et vous êtes la force
qui s'y trouvent
en première ligne vous payez d'héroïne
ont besoin de vous pour la première fois
un ambassadeur fait directement appel
aux français d'origine maghrébine ou
comment la double culture devienne
valeur ajoutée un atout dans un cv
[Musique]
à doha capitale du qatar certains n'ont
pas attendu le discours du diplomate ils
ont déjà mis le cap sur ce nouvel
eldorado
parmi eux il y abdel de la banlieue
lyonnaise le créateur de restaurants
brahim du gers aujourd'hui l'oeil du
qatar
karim de sarcelles le psychologue de
l'hôpital sportif high tech de doha et
puis farid le parisien architecte en
chef du nouvel aéroport international
c'est en réfléchissant français les
décisions se prennent en français vous
donnant aux nues
pourquoi ont-ils tout quitter pour ce
nouveau pays que les styles derrière eux
quand ils trouvaient au qatar
voyage au pays où les beurs sont heureux
[Musique]
à une quarantaine de kilomètres de lyon
villefontaine
une ville nouvelle une cité réputée
sensible où près d'un jeune sur deux est
au chômage quartier saint bonnet là où a
grandi abdel à 28 ans il est aujourd'hui
créateur de restaurants à doha
dans sa première vie quand ils étaient
chômeurs rmistes c'est entre ces
immeubles qu'abdel tuer le temps
le congrès qu'on est entre ces bâtiments
publics et quand les gens de notre âge
je pense
donc voilà ça ce petit centre commercial
c'est vrai qu'on est seul
c'est la comece réfugiés katic plus mais
qui faisait froid
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus rien presque
tous les magasins ont mis la clé sous la
porte et même les services publics comme
la poste ont déserté le quartier à
villefontaine l'horizon est bouché
derniers jours en france pour abdel il
est venu fêter l'aïd la fin du ramadan
demain il s'envole pour le qatar
derniers instants avec ses amis
d'enfance avec qui il a tout partagé
on profite de la dernière
ça me fait mon tour sonne aujourd'hui
plus
dauman hamada demain matin 6h
on a mangé assez le plus ici qu'en
maintenant j'ai toujours
d'aller là bas voir la vidéo
ah oui eh bah oui le soleil l'argent ne
donna
pas ici à ce cas la france les taxes et
à leur aile est parti à la guerre tout
seul son mec il s'est construit tout
seul et la personne qui la créent pas
d'âme
c'est important pour moi que je reviens
je peux pas dire les années parce que
c'est la famille comme je vous le disais
quand je suis pas là si ma maman a
besoin de quoi que ce soit
tous ces gens là là je sais qu'ils sont
à pouvoir donner c'est important d'être
un gars très heureux sur ces noirs garde
les pieds sur terre quand vous êtes avec
ce mois d'août une journée
train de parler de l'ariège et vous
retrouver du jour au lendemain dans un
bar
un cap et des
chômeurs rmistes ces voix là pour garder
les pieds sur terre c'est la quête sa
réussite ici
j'ai toujours pris conscience que de mes
défauts que des inconvénients ma tête de
basa né
mon adresse mon échec scolaire et c'est
seulement il faut que je me suis
expatrié je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais pack dès que des défauts que
j'avais aussi quelques talents et on en
a tous et puis on n'est pas que des
joueurs de foot ou que des gens qui
peuvent faire les pizzerias on sait
faire beaucoup d'autres choses se servir
notre cerveau aussi et ça
malheureusement il ya des gens qui ne
croient pas mais bon on va leur prouver
qu'ils ont tant charbon
partir l'angleterre quitter ma famille
je suis pas quelqu'un qui prétend partir
à l'aventuré comme ça se faisait avant
européen j'ai besoin d'eux on n'est pas
tous pareils moi je peux pas en manger
avons construit quelque chose ici mais
c'est dur la marque et dans un vrai si
des fois tu as un container pas en
embarquer de 3 d'ici je te donne les
noms on essaie un message merci pour
le lendemain roissy aéroport charles de
gaulle
costume de businessman port abdel il
s'apprête à décoller pour doha
qu'est ce que vous ressentez à quelques
minutes du départ ben on soit content de
rentrer à la maison mais un peu
un peu nostalgique de quitter la maison
aussi
mais bon
un petit pincement au coeur quand même
laissé derrière
mon pays
je laisse mon pays derrière ma jeunesse
ma famille mes amis mon chez moi
mais je laisse aussi qu'est un peu de
frustration un peu de de négativité un
peu de un peu de pessimisme donc voilà
que la banlieue c'est déjà derrière la
banlieue c'est derrière mais ça reste un
jeu donc comme comme on me disait
toujours abdel petit ils veulent la
banlieue mais la bo yu mettrai jamais
excusé moi
m
embarquement immédiat pour le jeunes de
la banlieue lyonnaise
sept heures de vol pour rejoindre la
capitale du petit émirat du golfe
persique
après dubaï doha c'est le nouvel
eldorado dans cette région des
pétrodollars
[Musique]
doha la ville qui ne dort jamais le
petit monaco du golfe la nouvelle vie
d'abdel arrivé ici il y a deux ans au
qatar pas de taxes et d'impôts la terre
de tous les possibles d'abord barmal à
londres un passage à dubaï abdellah
finalement poser ses valises à west bay
le nouveau quartier des affaires de doha
il habite toujours une tour mais cette
fois ci un bâtiment 5 étoiles
on a vraiment l'impression de la méthode
natalia tous les services dont on a
besoin salle de prière business center
la piscine le spa le salon
dans la tour beverly hills ne vivent que
des cadres expatriés comme abdel des
étrangers venus du monde entier attirés
par la manne du gaz et du pétrole
question comment on travaille on se pose
plus de questions combien on va faire la
fin du mois et qu'est ce qu'on va
pouvoir s'offrir avec donc voilà on se
pose les bonnes questions je pense
c'est l'agent est là pour ça on n'est
pas là pour le paysage on n'est pas non
plus on n'est pas non plus dans les
alpes suisses quoi au 21ème étage
l'appartement d'abdel du haut standing
3500 euros par mois payée par son
employeur
ce qui est modeste pour abel un
appartement de 180 m² contraste total
avec son trois-pièces de villefontaine
trop d'espacé pour moi mais bon on va
pas s'en plaindre dieu merci
donc voila quoi un espace
salon ici un espace télé
ici
donc c'est des appartements qui en
général sont tout meublé donc donc vous
arrivez avec vous posez vos valises et
puis ces prêts quoi
donc je vais faire mouvoir un peu le
balcon à vue parce qu'on a une vue qui
est assez sympa dc cam 1
c'est un pays qui essaie en cake est en
train d'essayer de faire en 20 ans ce
que ce que les pays du monde ont fait en
siècle donc c'est normal que c'est
complètement h en construction étaient
aussi tout est possible et les jeunes
français d'origine maghrébine ça passe
guèye s'est très très bien j'ai trés
j'ai la chance d'avoir un très bon
contact avec eux du fait que je sois
français mais d'origine arabe ça ça
m'aide énormément et
je pense que quelque part ça les rend
fier un petit peu des deux
de parler avec un français d'origine
arabe
parce que je suis français
avec tout ce que cela comprend mais je
ne suis pas amputer non plus mes
origines je suis aussi marocain avec
tout ce que cela comprend et ça pour eux
c'est formidable c'est formidable et
surtout 7
cette capacité d'adaptation avec ses
deux m'ont tellement différents procès
c'est incroyable la double culture
d'abdel un handicap à villefontaine ici
un atout le jeune français nous emmène
voir sa grande réussite
direction un des plus beaux palaces de
doha
à son arrivée
tapis rouge tous les employés
connaissent abdel
vous êtes les meilleurs légale c'est du
bon temps en famille ça va johnny je
suis contente 3
merci tout va bien
ce jour là il a rendez vous avec le
directeur de l'hôtel
voilà monsieur vitry
j'en ai jamais assez de vous embrasser
monsieur c'est donc le directeur général
de ce magnifique lieu
abdel est un garçon très innovant très
créatif il a de très grandes qualités
humaines
c'est quelqu'un de naturel il aime ce
qu'il fait il aime le contact avec les
autres vous êtes comme ça n'est ce pas
les trois restaurants du palace sont
signés abdel le jeune français a tout
repensé du menu au design ce qui marche
le mieux le marché aux poissons les
qatari en raffolent
voici le dernier restaurant dans lequel
abdellah travailler avant son départ
c'est un restaurant de poisson
c'est unique il n'en n'existe pas
ailleurs dans cette ville nous sommes
vraiment à l'avant garde
l'idée de départ était de créer une
ambiance de marché mais dans un grand
restaurant
à propos du bar qui devait pas se faire
et que j'ai insisté il s'est fait l'un
de ses seins le plus d'abdel au qatar la
raison pour laquelle on vient le
chercher c'est sa culture du service les
petits détails qui font la différence
l'autre chose qui est aussi un petit peu
française c'est d'avoir le pass du
restaurant dans les stands normalement
c'est dans une cuisine et moi je me
batte avec l'exécutif chef en fin de
compte j'ai gagné parce que le corporate
officer vraiment aimé l'idée c'est
d'avoir l'étiquette le passe ici ça
c'est aussi très français abdel est ici
comme chez lui
[Musique]
salut monsieur havel ça va vraiment bien
de l'hôtesse d'accueil au maître d'hôtel
c'est lui qui a formé le personnel abel
nous a appris à toujours être au top
être toujours créatif s'impliquer
totalement dans son travail et ils n'ont
rien laissé au hasard c'est très
important pour diriger le personnel
abdel nous a toujours dit que ça servait
à rien d'engueuler l'employé il faut
bien le coach il considérait comme un
frère il faut instaurer un esprit de
famille avec les équipes voilà c'est
fait tout ce que j'ai retenu de monsieur
abdel
abdel n'est pas le seul français
d'origine maghrébine à avoir trouvé un
bon job à doha il y à aussi brahim 42
ans et comme abdel depuis qu'il est là
il a toujours le sourire a priori rien
ne le prédestinait à cette nouvelle vie
mécanicien de formation il se décide sur
le tard à vivre de la photo des années
de galère en france et puis miracle un
appel du qatar brahim devient le
photographe officiel de la compagnie
aérienne du pays
mon bureau et la gêne que vos
ordinateurs ça fait beaucoup de jaloux
brand se présente son embauche s'est
joué en un clin d'oeil on m'appelle on
m'a dit écoutez monsieur je veux savoir
s'il pouvait venir dans une semaine
je me souviens la personne avait la
directrice du marketing à son agenda 10
voter mercredi prochain ça faisait une
semaine je peux vous voir à 10 heures
j'ai besoin d'une pense maintenant tout
simplement mais je lui dis ok et à une
semaine après j'étais le qatar de france
ça se passe pas comme ça
est ce que j'ai ressenti et puis surtout
j'ai fait quelques entretiens courants d
comme on voit arriver bon c'est le côté
malgré ben qui les gênent quoi et
pourtant je suis né dans le gers mundi
ville de 5000 habitants mirande dès que
vous avez sur votre cv dan brown même
menés en france
peu importe vos qualifications
et c'est vrai que j'ai un goût amer à ce
niveau là je ne dis pas qu'ils font tous
comme ça attention je ne dis pas qu'ils
font tous comme ça mais la majorité ça a
été clair ce niveau-là ça c'est vrai
ce serait
l'éloignement de sa famille de son petit
village du gers des températures qui
grimpe jusqu'à 50 degrés rien ne
décourage brahim en cas de blues ce qui
le fait tenir c'est sa passion
c'est difficile un peu j'ai plutôt le
regard de l'artiste je fais ça avec le
coeur j'ai beaucoup de gens qui sont
restés bouche bée en fait et qui me
disent mais comment t'as fait ça
ccc notre pays c'est nos gens c'est donc
là des fois il n'y a pas besoin de
mettre des sous titres sur la photo il
parle d'elle-même
[Musique]
à
la différence d'abdel brahim ne parlent
pas l'arabe peu importe il s'exprime
avec ces images
je ne parle pas le littéraire tout à
fait je parle de marocains c'est quand
même différent ici mais la plupart
parlent anglais donc donc ce n'est pas
un souci au niveau communication c'est
un souci plus tôt puis même quand ils
essayent de jeu fait un effort pour leur
parler un petit peu avec mes quelques
mots et j'ai appris en arabe ici et puis
il t'aide quoi ils sont très patients à
jouer c'est bien continue aussi de même
si tu fais des fautes on corrigera
d'encre toujours le côté l'hospitalité
je dirais que c'est une possibilité
que j'ai très rarement rencontrée quand
quand j'ai voyagé ou quand j'ai
travaillé dans des pays étrangers
lors de la dernière prière je
supprimerai
abdel et brahim ne se connaissaient pas
nous les avons fait se rencontrer
ils sont tous les deux musulmans abdel
va à la mosquée brahim lui il ne fait
pas ses prières
tout l'argent
[Musique]
et voilà quoi c'est une hygiène de vie
c'est comme se brosser les dents tu vois
tu prend d'habitude puis après c'est
après ça fait partie du train train tous
les jours que tous les jours pour abdel
le même rituel cinq prières quotidiennes
au qatar business et religions font bon
ménage
[Musique]
l'islam au qatar un islam moderne
l'idéal pour abdel
comment
très bien samedi là
ça se passe bien en delà
difficile de trouver une salle de prière
maintenant je vais là un maximum 400 500
mètres
dans les alentours quelle que soit
l'heure de la journée tienne prière il
ya une mosquée à disposition avec avec
tout ce qu'il faut pour les ablutions
donc hamdoullah là c'est vraiment pas un
problème de faire ses prières ici et ça
c'est vrai que c'est un luxe pour moi
alors qu'en france c'est plus un
parcours du combattant de s'organiser
quand c'est la savate la seule où il
dort on connaît en voiture qu'on est en
ville à la façon de rentrer chez soi
était de toutes les réunir les prières
ce qui est pas très très bien mais bon
un
islam ouvert tolérant à l'islam
l'islam que j'ai toujours connu qu un
islam global
[Musique]
abdel est un jeune homme pressé après la
mosquée vite retour au boulot
il vient de créer sa propre société il a
ouvert son premier restaurant
adele a rendez vous avec celui qui le
finance
il y à un passage obligé au qatar pour
ouvrir une affaire il faut
obligatoirement s'associer à un qatari
de souche il détient 49%
voici le parrain d'abdel monsieur ali
comme il l'appelle n'a que 24 ans il est
l'actionnaire principal d'un groupe
financier qui pèse 800 millions de
dollars
tout le monde va bien chez vous vous
avez passé une bonne fête de l'aïd en
france grâce à dieu merci d' attaque
pour reprendre le boulot oui je suis
d'attac j'ai revu toute ma famille et
mes amis il me manquait vraiment
beaucoup
les opportunités de financement au qatar
sont énormes
c'est un pays vierge nous avons tout
pour réussir
et il y a un boulevard pour tous ceux
qui veulent s'engager receipts
doha un immense gâteau que se partager
les grands groupes internationaux une
oasis de prospérité en pleine crise
mondiale
ici pas de problèmes de liquidités pour
freiner les affaires avec l'argent du
pétrole et du gaz doha ressemble à un
immense chantier
un des plus gros contrats du moment
c'est le nouvel aéroport de l'émirat
contre a raflé par un groupe français
aéroports de paris
stratégie d'entreprise adp a compris
l'intérêt que pouvait représenter des
salariés de la diversité ici
l'architecte en chef s'appelle farid
parisien du xivème arrondissement
d'origine algérienne
pièce d'identité
ben barnes
ma gueule
c'est que
[Musique]
farid nous ouvre les portes de l'un des
plus grands chantiers au monde
après une longue période de chômage en
france il est au qatar depuis deux ans
sa mission faire sortir de terre la tour
de contrôle du futur aéroport mais aussi
36 bâtiments dans le très prestigieux
pavillon privé de l'émir du qatar
podium donc cette partie là donc il est
dédié donc aux ministres et aux vip
la partie qui diront la lumière et à
l'entourage
un chantier ultra sensible pour lequel
farine n'a pas le droit à l'erreur il
dirige une équipe de 9 personnes pour se
parler l'arabe l'anglais et le français
trois langues que maîtrise l'architecte
en chef
en a promis hier le bas des collines 1
alors à dubai world bastian chine
ok de soins to be ça doit être l'acteur
notre arabité aujourd'hui on a montré ce
que je double culturel
les la coi sur une certaine proximité
culturelle une certaine proximité
linguistique et ça ça rassure c'est
clair c'est simple puce ça vous a permis
ne sais pas
le client fait oui bien sûr le client
est très très sensibles à ça oui bien
sûr bien entendu jouer pour gagner sa
confiance
oui non mis à cette proximité déjà
linguistique cette proximité culturelle
elle est allée
oui elle est au service de l'entreprise
aujourd'hui ce jeu
de quelque chose à comprendre à la
farid et sa diversité au service d'une
entreprise qui lui a offert à 40 ans son
premier contrat à durée indéterminée
et voilà notre fierté c'est ça c'est de
voir ça voir ce qu'on a dessiné
des signes des pays voilà
voilà ça c'est un moment de bonheur
absolu
c'est la friture
la french touch la touche française un
bon argument de vente au qatar les
relations entre les deux pays sont
excellentes
les projets les plus ambitieux ont été
conçus par des français comme ici le
musée islamique flambant neuf
l'autre fierté du qatar un hôpital pas
tout à fait comme les autres une
structure de soins ultra moderne destiné
aux sportifs de haut niveau
en chemisette karim dirige depuis deux
ans le service de psychologie il vient
de sarcelles le but de l'exercice est
frappée dans ce sac faire un peu comme
la boxe base y montre comment tu feras
pas c'est important fais comme si tu
shooter dans un ballon mais tu remplaces
le ballon par ce sac est épié par tes
mains
vas-y
fera pas dicter man fera pas l'économie
sociale
je frappe d'un seul coup comme tu veux
le patient est footballeur professionnel
ils s'en remettent à karim le psy
incompris de sarcelles c'est un hôpital
d'excellence où je retrouve en me
reconnais dans ce que je fais et je suis
reconnu par les compétences et bien sûr
ça fait plaisir donc c'est un appel
épanouissement personnel et
professionnel en france
c'est autre chose oui c'est autre chose
effectivement c'est un parcours commence
un parcours pour ma part difficile très
difficile
c'est à dire que on est nouveau
d'obtenir des diplômes libéraux
effectivement d'avoir achevé des sous
mais de vie vouloir apprendre et évoluer
dans la vie et on se dit il est temps de
travail et donc du passage du savoir il
faudra y travailler dans une institution
pour apporter partie du soin pour les
sociétés j'ai sentir utile et donc
bien sûr au sens large effectivement un
mur
à mur on peut rien faire devant son
nouveau 20 ans d'études pour karim un
surdiplômés qui n'intéressaient personne
quand il habitait en banlieue parisienne
ici c'est le profil recherché
ces deux hommes en habit traditionnel
blanc sont des proches de l'émir du
qatar les docteurs el houari et ghanem
dirige l'hôpital ils veulent faire de
leur complexe le numéro un au monde il
s'en donne les moyens et assume le
recrutement
nous avons fait appel à des médecins
français d'origine arabe car ils sont
proches de nous et ils ont la fibre
arabe ils comprennent bien la culture et
les traditions du qatar
il met en pratique ses connaissances au
profit de notre hôpital
avec en plus un savoir faire occidental
que nous recherchons particulièrement
[Musique]
c'est pour nous le dernier soir au pays
où les beurs sont heureux
le souk de doha le lieu de sortie des
expatriés après des journées très
chargées
abdel ibrahim ont tenu à nous inviter au
tajine la table préférée des français de
doha
mal du pays ou juste envie de se
retrouver entre eux et de savourer
pleinement leur aventure au qatar j'ai
une chance
c'était juste un rêve
maintenant si c'est vraiment de
bien prendre soin de ma famille j'ai
laissés derrière en france entre autres
ma mère mes frères mes soeurs
ouais c'est prendre soin but est de
partager le succès un vécu pourvu que ça
dure car les chocolats pourvu que ça
dure c'est vrai que ça dure y'a pas de
raison qu'il
n'y a pas de raison qu'il est
des français d'origine maghrébine
contraint à l'exil pour réussir
comme brahim abdel farid et karim ils
sont aujourd'hui quelques milliers à
s'être fait une place au soleil dans les
pays du golfe